[Música]
como está pasando
ya habrá más ánimo por cómo está pasando
súper bien bueno como me presentaron mi
nombre es más no más tengo 19 años
estudió ingeniería comercial en la
universidad católica y hoy día vengo
hablarles de algo súper particular
a cuántos de ustedes no le ha pasado que
me levante la mano a las personas que
les gusta leer primeras personas a sonar
y los demás qué onda
como lo encuentran
o río a lo mejor no le llama la atención
[Música]
y hubiera quiero hablar un poquito de
esto
cuando me presentaron y dijeron que el
escritor que además era músico a lo
mejor se imaginaron de que soy un
viciado de la literatura pero esto no
siempre fue así
un tiempo un pequeño lapsus en el que
estaba negado por la literatura o sea
cuando me mandan a leer un libro me leía
el resumen del resumen del resumen que
tienen a cuánto en el espacio cuando era
joven bueno resulta que
nunca pero nunca nunca tomé un libro
porque a mí me parecía que era lo
correcto
entonces
y avanzando el tiempo y en mi colegio
nos ganamos un premio y nos llevaron al
molde el trébol en donde el director del
colegio nos dijo elige en el libro que
quieran chicos yo se los compro
buen premio muy buen premio pero para mí
no gracias entonces mientras mis
compañeros están eligiendo la última de
harry potter y el libro que estaba de
moda en ese tiempo yo estaba dentro de
un anaquel que estaba esperando que todo
estuvieran listos para poder irnos
resulta que cuando estamos por irnos el
director me dice oye tú
y tu libro que le quite
gracias
vamos no la cosa no funciona así busca
pero tú tienes que elegir un libro elige
lo el que tú quieras yo te lo compro
dejara de molestar
el primer libro que había al lado de la
persona que estaba haciendo los pagos
envolvió en una bolsa y listo me fue
para la casa y no lo habría durante tres
días tres días sin abrir la bolsa no
sabía qué era lo que había comprado
resulta que tenía un cumpleaños y la
bolsa está bonita
así que me compré un chocolate para la
cumpleañera y tuve que sacar el libro de
la bolsa lo dejé boca arriba encima de
la cama pero compraré lo pasamos che r
resulta que vuelvo y veo el libro
el libro sin nombre
anonimo cuando lo vi dije proyecto como
el libro no va a tener título
entonces el libro me pareció tan
increíble tan interesante que le di la
vuelta y me di cuenta de que era
totalmente adverso todo lo que había
esto era diferente al papelucho era
diferente a su tierra era diferente a
todo lo que había visto en mi etapa
escolar
este libro tenía tres 350 360 páginas y
yo una persona que no le gustaba leer me
lo dio vuelta en tres días entonces dije
que fuerte
a una persona que no le gustaba leer un
libro imagínense unas cositas y
chiquititas fue capaz de cambiarle la
vida a una persona
yo dije cuando sea grande quiero lograr
los mismos con los demás quiero escribir
un libro que sea capaz de hacer que una
persona que no le gusta la literatura
por fin le guste
resulta que me gusta escribir me puse a
leer ya por un poquito más de gusto
y empecé a agarrar manías de otros
escritores y empecé a escribir
un par de concurso literario los
primeros fueron en la básica después
concurrieron algunos de la media
pero no había escrito nada lo
suficientemente bueno según yo para
darlo a conocer
resulta que en 2016 yo me tomo un lapsus
había dado la psv muy bien entonces tomé
un preuniversitario y mientras estaba en
el pri llamó a mi papá y me dice oye
sabes lo que es la aguja literaria
no es tarea para la casa así que me puse
a buscar y me percaté de que la aguja
literaria era un concurso un certamen de
literatura a nivel nacional que estaba
pasando en santiago y yo no podía mandar
su texto y se podía ganar la publicación
del libro no tenía nada para publicar
tenía una historia que se basaba en una
página
resulta que yo porfiado me queda un mes
para poder participar
y manny me animé y me puse a escribir me
puse a investigar y le di vida a mi
primer libro
lo llevé al concurso
esperé a que viera los resultados y que
pasa llega el día de los resultados y yo
estaba con mi teléfono y estaba buscando
realmente anunciamos los ganadores del
concurso nacional de la aguja literaria
tercer lugar
no yo bien sobre
segundo lugar
super bien
en primer lugar no hay
que algo raro pasa aquí
y es que la vida te da siempre dos
caminos no gane el concurso y me pude
haber desanimado como muchas personas lo
hacen sin embargo me latía de porfiado
busque editoriales
golpe de 23 puertas editoriales de chile
más las 23 me dijeron que no porque era
muy joven porque no tenía los recursos
monetarios porque mi nombre no era
atractivo
por un sinfín de cosas
llegó a amazon esta plataforma
internacional y donde se me permite
finalmente publicar mi libro y en 24
horas mi libro estaba dando la vuelta al
mundo ese libro que las editoriales
chilenas habían rechazado estaba dando
la vuelta al mundo al día siguiente
paradójicamente me llega un mensaje por
redes sociales de una policía española
galicia me dice ostia que ha leído tu
libro que ha encantado
y ellas
en españa llevan seis mil libros y claro
que no el libro estaba dando ocho y en
eso de dos meses por aquí está la puerta
de mi libro a ver sí
es la puerta de mi libro ya los dos
meses pasó algo increíble y yo no me
esperaba que fuera a pasar
este libro ese libro que había sido
rechazado por tanta gente ese libro que
había sido tremendamente criticado
la cosa no funciona se había
transformado
en un best-seller
en tres países
estados unidos méxico y españa wow qué
onda por qué pasó esto si me dijeron que
era malo
y aquí me surge una pregunta
las editoriales chilenas están realmente
interesadas en el talento de las
personas o están interesadas en lo que
les dejé en la parte de atrás del
pantalón
entonces
tomando esta idea me puse a hacer
charlas motivacionales a motivar a la
gente a decirle que si se podía que si
se podía conseguir las cosas cuando uno
las tenía claramente porque si existe en
tu mente existe para todo el mundo
entonces dentro de esas charlas me tocó
dar una charla en uno de los colegios
más pobres de acá de la zona de
concepción y soy el coronel por si acaso
y en este colegio empecé a dar la charla
había mucha gente como ustedes
pero vio una persona una pequeña
personita que estaba sentada en la parte
izquierda
nacía una cantidad de preguntas yo
avanzaba cinco minutos intervenidas y me
levantaba la mano mencias tengo una
pregunta espera me espera
listo la primera la segunda vaca
pero ya como la séptima en la octava yo
estaba
entonces resumiendo termina la charla
y la gente se acerca se saca fotos de la
firma y todo el rollo pero una persona
se acercó entre medio de toda la
multitud y se ganó aquí al medio me miró
de frente
y me dio las gracias
y me dio un abrazo
aquí
la propia se acerca es esta chiquilla
tiene una historia de vida tremenda
esta chica pertenece una familia donde
el papá es un alcohólico
que una noche llegó a la casa pateando
la puerta destruyó todo lo que había a
su paso y le pegó la mamá la dejó
inconsciente en el suelo
la niña
se metió a su pieza cerró la puerta con
llave y se puso a escribir
el papá iba decidido a ir a la pieza de
ella pero su hermano intervino
y también le pego
finalmente
destrozó la puerta de la niña el
arrebato lo que tenía entre medio de las
manos
y quizás que a ghana le puso el anillo
porque el papá finalmente le pego
pero le quemó su cuaderno su cuaderno
donde tenía todo lo que había escrito
y desde ese día la niña no escribía
ahí fue cuando yo entendí que ese
gracias ese abrazo
me devolviste la esperanza
quiero volver a escribir
me dio un abrazo
cuando supe esto se me llenó el ojo de
larga salir del lugar fui y ahora se la
nieve
gracias le dije gracias a ti te quiero
ayudar
luego la profe alegó en la dirección del
pp
para que le prestaron un computador en
el krafft y que ella pudiera escribir y
subir sus textos a la nube porque hoy en
día la tecnología te permite hacer cosas
increíbles entonces ella ya no iba a
tener el problema de que el papá le
fuera a llamar de nuevo sus cuentos
todos sus textos están almacenados en la
nube y cuando tuvo una cantidad de
textos considerables para publicar
a lo que más estamos listos
así que tomamos los textos y los
publicamos en amazon
en físico entiende lo que es entonces el
colli que es un esfuerzo sobrehumano y
compró 20 ejemplares de ese libro y los
vendió en una reunión de apoderados y
con la plata que recaudaron metieron al
papá a un centro de rehabilitación
al tiempo me llama a la niña y me dice
germán gracias por lo que hiciste
mi papá salió del centro de
rehabilitación está mucho mejor volvió a
la casa y leyó mi libro
aquí yo dije esto es lo mío
me encanta lo que estoy haciendo y
quiero seguirlo haciendo
pero como y aquí nace
un proyecto increíble yo estoy enamorado
de él
editorial combas que fue fundada junto a
un grande de la literatura que está aquí
también alejandro concha que quiero que
le demos un abrazo gigante antes de ir
entonces
con editorial com vas
hemos logrado muchas cosas dentro de
ellas haber publicado a siete autores
nacionales y uno mexicano
por aquí está lo a ver
y dentro de ellos está la historia de la
señora honda una señora de 69 años que
llegó acepto básico
pero que guarda toda la historia de
coronel dentro de esas páginas
y tres gigantes como la vez que tuvimos
un campeón nacional de boxeo y que murió
porque se suicidó
también tenemos el mantra poético que ha
de nicola bravo a nicola yo lo conocí
afuera de la facultad de medicina en la
católica estaba llorando estaba
destrozado
y bueno una empatía se elige compadre
está bien necesita
se me dijo
este paso
terminé con mi voluble y estoy
desesperado
y yo escribo mejor
y escribe un besito
y escribamos decir
pero me gustaría no sé mandar empastar
mi libro y poder regalárselo a ver si
mañana
se pudo publicar
compare el entregó el libro a su polola
orgulloso
y volvieron
después terminaron como la semana pero
ya no
entonces bueno ahí están siete autores
chilenos
bueno mexicanos que tienen ahora se
preguntarán qué estoy haciendo
estoy trabajando en la segunda parte del
libro
la cuarta de imperfecta que se llama el
hospital de los lamentos que va a estar
listo en 2019
va a estar disponible lawson y bueno
el hecho de haber emprendido mi primer
negocio mi primer gran desafío que era
la editorial me animé junto a una
persona que estaba sentada ahí atrás a
fundar mi primera empresa que es de
marketing digital que se llama innovas
con la cual le damos soluciones
pragmáticas a los a las personas que
están recién empezando a emprender a los
startups a los pequeños emprendedores
que prefieren invertir 30 lucas en
productos para poder capitalizarse que
invertir 30 lucas en poder hacer un
logotipo visualmente atractivo para su
empresa yo considero que es más
importante es y no lo hacen porque hacer
un logotipo mucho más caro
entonces nosotros hicimos un costo
diferido para emprendedores y
conseguimos combas que con el tiempo
también logramos hacer junto con una
alianza estratégica una versión de
combat sport
ambientada para que las personas pierdan
el sedentarismo y vuelven a la actividad
física sin necesidad de ir al gimnasio
sino con el propio peso de su cuerpo
entonces cuando las personas me dicen
juego tiene 19 años has hecho cosas
increíbles
este libro para que sepan y para que
estén atentos las redes sociales de
ahora en adelante le están haciendo una
película en costa rica y se está
traduciendo a 5 idiomas
cuando alguien a mí me pregunta
o me dice no se puede
yo le digo
se vale
siempre se puede puede que tu familia te
diga que no puede que tus amigos más
cercanos te digan que no puede que la
vida entera te diga que no puede que el
mundo esté confabulando en contra tuyo
para que tú no compras tu propósito pero
hay algo que tú tienes que tener siempre
en cuenta la única persona que tiene que
decir que sí siempre en todo momento y
en todo lugar eres tú mismo por qué
porque cuando tú cumples tu propósito
cuando tú cumples tu meta vas a poder
decir con orgullo que el único no que
dijiste fue un no me voy a rendir muchas
gracias
[Música]
y